did you know that there's a movement
right now to get a woman on the $20 bill
I did not know that good question for
you who was on the $20 bill Benjamin
Franklin I wouldn't be able to tell you
that until I look at a $20 bill who is
that guy Jackson nailed it
his first name's Andrew his last name is
Jackson he was a general in one of the
thumb war he ruled the country for a
little bit a lot of presidents who
aren't on the $20 bill why him I guess
because he had a cool haircut I couldn't
tell you that sorry I would know that
one I don't think anyone does do you
think that it's time that we had a woman
on the $20 bill ever be nice Hillary
Clinton honestly I love Whitney Houston
let's see Whitney Houston on it if I
have to stay off the top of my head I
would say Michelle Obama you know what I
would say Justina Machado who's Justina
Machado she played the wife of Freddie
all Six Feet Under
there is a movement right now to get a
woman on the $20 bill by 2020 they've
nominated for women to be on the bill
there is a Cherokee Indian chief Wilma
Mankiller which i think is ironic and
funny and I like okay Rosa Parks oh yeah
all about Harriet something as well of
the four of them I would say Rosa Parks
Harriet Tubman's definitely an important
choice too so either to Eleanor
Roosevelt probably
Roosevelt Harriet Tubman Underground
Railroad and we're gonna do enough to
honor black people on the bills probably
that man killer woman whoever she is did
you say Cicely Tyson
[Music]
the Energex is like the worst the Trail
of Tears the terrible human being just
hated Indians
[Music]